Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and as some Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
February 10th, 2015. How's it going? How,
um,
I'm back in the USA.
I just landed at JFK a couple of hours
ago and I've been trying to get this
fucking thing done in my,
my Olympus ls 10 that I bought like six,
seven fucking years ago.
It finally died.
I think it finally died after
a trip around the world.
The old girl couldn't take it,
you know, she went quietly,
quietly in the night. Um, anyway,
so I'm psyched to be back.
I had a great time and just a
whirlwind tour around the world.
I don't even know where the fuck I am
right now and I don't even know what time
it is. Um, yeah, I do.
It's 5:53 PM east coast
time according to my, um,
my little fucking little, little
iPad thing here. Uh, Ah Shit,
I don't know what to tell you guys.
What the fuck do you want from me?
You know all you can see out there who,
who gave me shit because the
podcast is so late this week.
All right?
You didn't have the fucking decency Digi
to go onto my website and maybe have a
little bit of empathy. You'd
be like, Oh, oh, that's why.
That's why it's late. He's
flying back from Mumbai, India.
Okay.
It's fucking three hours to do by another
fucking 13 hours on the Goddamn plane
at some dose.
Miss Their connection when we were in
Dubai in their plane was on their planes.
That bag was on the plane,
so they don't let the
cont on the plane yet.
They spend 15 minutes trying to find 20
minutes trying to find the fucking bag
and they take it off the plane. It's
like, at that point, why don't you,
let's just let the asshole on the plane
so we can all get outta here. Right.
I mean, that's what I was doing. Well,
you know when I used to run an airline,
that's how I did it.
So I don't know what's going on with
United Arab Emirates and Mercedes,
whatever the fuck the airline
is that I flew. Uh, anyways,
first of all,
before I get going,
thank you to everybody came out
to my shows in India, China,
Singapore or whatever the
fuck I was this week. Uh,
it was my first trip to
fuck in Asia and I had a, a,
a great time. I did not
get caned in Singapore. Um,
I didn't have any secret police in China
and no religious crazy people got me
when I was in India, you
know, so I, I survived it.
Singapore was great. China was great. I
don't fucking know what to tell you all.
Let's just talk about India.
All right? First and foremost,
the second you get to India, this is
what you're going to see. Mumbai, India,
you are going to see the greatest drivers
in Jay Walker's you've ever seen in
your fucking life.
I've never seen just complete fucking
chaos when it comes driving. Like,
like I saw in India and even like the
old people were good at Jay walking and
what killed me.
They never changed their gait,
I guess gay does that running whatever,
whatever fucking speed they were walking
when they stepped down and traffic,
they just stepped out and just kept
walking at the same pace to traffic.
Never sped up, never slowed down.
Nobody got hit. It was unreal.
I've never been in the back of a cab
so many times going, ah, well watch it,
watch it, watch it. And just nobody
slows down. Nobody speeds up.
Everybody just keeps doing what
they're doing. It's like, it was like,
it's like watching Chevy chase and
Caddyshack when he's a fucking Putin
barefoot. No, no, no, no, no,
no. Saturday Dah, Dah, Dah.
That's how they fucking do it.
I'm definitely the most insane,
craziest,
coolest country I've ever
been to was definitely, uh,
at least that city man that was,
um,
it was something else that people
were really cool. Uh, you know,
at first you freak out, you
know, when you show up. And uh,
we landed there at like midnight.
Okay.
And, um, you know,
we showed up to the hotel and there's
a guy with like a machine gun in
somebody's checking for bombs
underneath the fucking car, you know,
which creeped me out at first.
And there was like a metal detector
going into the fucking hotel within.
I was just like, ah, now that I'm in here,
I got a guy with a machine
guns standing up front.
This is way better than a red roof inn.
So I guess it's just a big,
I guess maybe back in 2008,
they had a terrorist attack.
So ever since then and the hotel
was and get attacked or whatever.
So now they just have a guard. They
were all the time. But other than that,
I didn't see anybody with a gun.
It's a really safe city.
The food was fucking tremendous.
And uh,
I did the show the last show of the,
um,
okay.
Of the, uh, of the tour. Sorry guys. It's
going to be a lot of fucking mental, uh,
brain farts here this week. I'm just
trying to take in everything that I saw.
Um,
it was awesome and I got
to hang out afterwards and
went out and got dinner with
me and like 20 Indian comics and just
sat there talking comedy for a good half
hour, 45 minutes before I had to
go to, uh, the airport, which was,
uh, one of the highlights of my
career to be honest with you,
have to be able to talk to people on the
other side of the world that do what I
do. You know, and um, you know, this,
these guys want to send
you a link to this,
although maybe I shouldn't because
I know that trying to lay low,
but for those who listened to
the podcast I did over there,
those same guys got in trouble because
they just did a fucking roast. Right.
And according to them, it was way tamer
than anything in the, in the u s but uh,
they haven't had, I guess a lot of
roasts that might've been the first one.
And they did it,
they roast it.
A couple of Bollywood guys and
everything was fine. Everybody laughed,
everybody had a good time.
And then for whatever reason,
either they posted it online or somebody
else did and the second went online,
you know, you know what happens?
The second something goes online,
everybody starts going, oh my
God, what about the children?
What about the fucking religious
thing that I believe in?
What will this comedy due to that?
You know what I mean? Like they will,
it's just fucking roast. Everybody's
laughing, having a good time, so whatever.
So they,
everybody freaked out and um,
you've got like 8 million hits and uh,
they're like sort of in trouble but
not in trouble, but they're in trouble.
Like they could spend
eight years in courts with,
I dunno what lawsuits or whatever.
I was reading some of the comments and
someone was just going like, you know,
what does this say? What is this going to
do to society and Blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. And it's like, have you fucking
looked out your window over there?
Jesus Christ,
they got like in New Delhi,
they have like a major problem with rape.
Is a roast going to make that any worse?
You know what I mean?
Jesus crabbing.
I mean,
I'm not even going to fucking say some
of the shit that I saw over there.
I saw a stray cow,
a stray cow.
It's just as fucking,
it's awesome. I don't see,
I don't want to say a half of this shit
cause I don't want to scare people from
going over there because it's one of the
coolest fucking places I ever went to.
Um, but yeah, you'll see like a
stray cow eating garbage next to her.
Like a Mercedes Benz driving
by. Okay. So you got,
you got the entire fucking colors
of the rainbow there. It was.
It was awesome man. And the
uh, the food was insane.
Can't say enough about that.
And um,
okay.
Other than that,
what else did I get a chance to see?
I didn't get a chance
to see her. They, oh,
this was the scary thing was I went into
the country and because we we fuck with,
with the Indian people when
they come to the u s I guess,
cause we're trying to make sure that they
don't illegally immigrate, immigrate,
whatever to our fucking country immigrant.
Right.
And immigrate. Yeah. Immigrant. That's
how it is. Emigrate, you leave, immigrate,
you come in, there you go, Bill. Now
you worked out yourself then. Yeah. Um,
anyways, so we fuck with them.
So this is tit for tat thing.
So then they fuck with us, specifically
Americans from the west coast.
So they don't fuck with anybody
from the east coast I guess.
Okay.
Um, as far as like you come to the country
and then once you get to the country,
you,
you need another piece of paper stamped
by the government so you could fucking
leave, you know, or it's
some Bronx tale shit.
Like now you can't leave until you
get this fucking thing and then it's,
yeah.
You know,
just some big pain in the ass thing.
That took like two and a half
hours for me to get. But, um,
I guess they've had problems
with artists on the west coast,
but not in the east coast,
which means to me that maybe somebody,
a governor or a senator of
a state on the west coast,
like maybe Schwartzenegger said something.
I have no idea what,
but somebody said something, somebody
pissed off, somebody snuck. So you know,
old freckles has got to get up in the
fucking morning and I go down to a,
I didn't know what the hell it was,
but I had this,
this big like envelope
as shit with my passport,
my working visa, the fucking contract
for the show, all of that stuff.
I go inside the building and the,
the promoters not allowed to go with me.
So now I'm in there.
I mean this was like one of the biggest
like touristy things that I got to do,
like really experienced,
be in an Indian and I fucking go up to
the third floor and this big long line of
people all from different countries
trying to get this piece of paper so they
can fucking leave and a,
the line move quickly.
But then they just got you into another
room and it was like being at the
fucking DMV and you know how that goes.
You're going to show up
with a stack of papers,
like the God damn phone book
and when you get up there,
you just see the look on their face. You
like, Oh fuck you. What else do I need?
And there's always something else.
So whatever.
I kind of charmed the lady I was talking
to like, uh, I couldn't understand her,
she couldn't really understand me and
I finally was able to convey it to her
that I was a comedian and she
kind of gave me this look like,
really? You think you're funny?
And I forget what the fuck I said,
but I was able to make a smile,
which was good because eventually I needed
the promoter to come up there to help
me get over the last leg of it.
But what's funny about Indian people is
they got this thing they do when you ask
them a question, they don't
shake their head no or not. Yes,
they do like this bobblehead thing.
And I was sitting there like this white
dude in Hong Kong told me that they're
going to do that.
And it actually means yes,
you're going to think that they're being
assholes, but it actually means yes.
So this lady kept doing it. I kept
going. Does that mean yes. I mean, yes.
Long story short, one of the comics told
me later on that it doesn't mean yes,
it doesn't mean no. It means that
there, how did he put it there? Uh,
okay.
Politely accepting your existence
or something like that. Yeah,
what it was.
But um,
yeah,
everybody that I asked a
question too there, I was like,
so if I give him all this stuff,
like I'm going to be able to get
to piece of paper, I'll be fine.
And then they do like that bobble
head like a, you know, maybe you will,
maybe you won't,
you know,
maybe you'll be on that plane back
to the u s maybe a you'll be in that.
You'd be in the garbage next to the cow
tomorrow. I don't know. I don't know how.
I don't,
I don't know what to tell you.
So I'm just going to do this
fucking thing with my head.
So I got a big kick out of that.
And here's the thing too.
Like I've really been
working on my temper.
I stayed up there for two hours and 45
minutes. I never lost my temper once.
At one point, I sat down, I looked
over at the lady and I was just like,
I looked down at the floor,
it's like,
how fucking long as it's going
to fucking this the worst.
I got sort of whispered debt,
but then I just looked around the room
and I saw this family of four from the
Philippines and they would in front
of me and I'm like, all right,
they're still here. The guy
was behind me, he's still here,
so everybody's waiting the same amount
of time, you know, for the love of God,
Bill fucking relax. Um, so whatever.
But uh, I just um, got, okay,
I saw so much shit over there so
quickly went down to this. Um,
they haven't like the street fair
thing and they had all this, you know,
brought my wife down there.
They had all this amazing clothing and
all that type of shit and artwork and all
that type of stuff. I, it's just one of
those things. You just walk around like,
I'm, I'm in fucking India right
now. I couldn't believe it. And, uh,
then what's funny is you go out to go
do the show and you feel like you're in
the United States. It's the exact same
thing. People laugh at the same shit.
It's just that when Singapore,
Hong Kong and India,
they had like these, you know,
don't talk about the government,
don't talk about religion,
don't talk about race.
And then you go to the show and the comic
in front of you is talking about all
of that shit and basically how it works
for you to really get in trouble with
that. You would have to be
basically living in the country,
build up a reputation for
doing it all the time.
And then eventually one of
those governments will be
like, all right, let's see,
let's send somebody down there. And
then they'd go down, they'd watch you.
And in all you'd get is like a fine,
either they'd find the promoter or the
venue or possibly the performer. I Dunno.
It's not really like, you know, harshly,
um,
and forced,
which is actually was a pleasant
surprise with the way everybody's taking
everything.
So God damn seriously lately,
like every fucking thing that
you say now is just like,
okay,
I mean it's fucking ridiculous and I
really think comics have to hold the
fucking line here and
not apologize or else,
I mean,
I don't know where it goes from there
unless you want comedians just up there
talking about widgets.
Um,
and what kills me about the so called
outrageous is such a small percentage of
the population.
First of all,
you realize how many people could
just give a fuck about standup comedy.
Like if you walked down to the amount
of people that the small percentage of
people who've actually been
to a live show, you know,
it doesn't even fucking appeal to like
80% of the population as far as I know.
You know what I mean?
They're doing other things.
There may be into music or they just
watch sports, but like, you know,
it's fucked up. Like, I love standup
comedy before I became a comedian.
I only went to one show ever and I was
almost 24 by the time I started so I
could legally could have gone to
stand up shows for like six years,
18 plus. And then once I was 21 I
could go to anything and I never went.
I only went one time and I
wanted to do it for a living. So
I dunno.
All right.
And of course this stupid
thing just crapped out on me.
I'm really having a rough go here
with the technology on the strip.
I apologize to everybody. Uh,
anyways, what was I saying? Um,
I guess I was just talking about how few
people actually even give a shit enough
to even go to a standup show.
Um, so if a comic says something,
it's really not affecting that much of
the population that really they could
have fuck lives their life by what a
fucking comedian says and a God damn joke.
It's so ridiculous. It's
just gotta be a, I dunno,
I'm really hoping this is just a fad
to be taking comedian seriously.
Anyways, that's the end of the whole,
um, the whole world w world tour thing.
Um, it was really insane. I went
to five countries in three weeks.
I did a 11 shows in nine different cities,
five different countries.
I don't know how many
different time zones and uh,
so first time I ever was in Asia and um,
I had just, it was, it's just a part of
the world. I never, I always wanted to go,
you know, and I just never, you know,
he's just don't think you're ever going
to get to do something like that. So, uh,
thanks to everybody
listening to this podcast,
watch us my specials and all that type
of shit and actually learned something.
People downloading my specials illegally
isn't always a bad thing. I mean,
it kills me monetarily,
but had they not done that overseas,
then they wouldn't have
seen me. So, uh, I dunno.
I'm starting to rethink some of that shit.
Although I do stand hard is far as
I got a hard line on the fucking,
I stand hard yet with my dick standing up.
I got a hard line when it comes to fucking
tape and be in a club when I'm trying
out new shit. Um, that's,
that's fucking brutal cause then I go
to town and my new shit is already old
shit and it's just,
you can't write fast enough,
so can all you fucking teeny boppers uh,
just take that into consideration.
I know it's all about you and your
fucking Facebook pages now and Oh my God,
look at me with my selfie and all of that
shit. It's, this was fucking hilarious.
Now is this like the crowd wants
to be famous back in the day.
The crowd was cool when they would
just sat there. All right, monkey boy.
He wanted to be famous. Let's see
if you're good enough to be famous.
Now it's like half of them aren't
even paying attention to you.
They're literally like really bill.
Is that half of them or is it like three,
four people is show?
All right.
Three or four people is show are like
already on their Twitter accounts or
Facebook or whatever the fuck they use.
Um,
talking about themselves,
trying to put myself in their position,
but I just can't picture myself any show
I ever went to when I was a kid. Right.
You know, if I paid to go see it,
I would watch it, wouldn't you?
He got all fucking day to do your duck
face into the phone, don't ya? All right,
let's do a little, a little bit of
advertising here. A Sherry's berries.
Everybody time is running out.
That is the theme.
Everybody that was written
in all capital letters,
I guess I was supposed to scream that
time is running out Valentine's date this
weekend. Don't give yourself a headache
shopping for a gift. Yeah. Why would you?
It's a completely bullshit holiday.
This is why I love Sherry's berries.
Just get her some chocolate
covered strawberries.
If somebody else picked and then dipped
in chocolate and then your frisbee him
across the table, it go, there you go.
Touch. What do you do you think? Huh?
Love you too. Anyways, keep calm
and Barry on with Sherry's berries.
Uh,
forget the long lines and crazy shoppers.
I love how they're acting
like it's Christmas.
Sherry's berries will deliver
this decadent treat directly
to her door with love
from you. Spend less time shopping
and more time with you, sweetheart.
This Valentine's Day,
giant,
freshly right dip strawberries from
Sherry Sperry starting at just 1999 over a
40% savings. Go to Barry's
dot com that's B. E. R. R. I,
e. S, despite how I pronounce it, Dot Com.
Click on the microphone and type in
my code burpee. You are our info,
my listeners,
you can double the berries for just
$10 more, but you have to use my code.
Burr B, u. R. R. Additional
copy points. Choose one or two.
Oh No, I'm doing them off. All right.
These Sherry's berries are dipped
in white milk and dark chocolate,
chocolate. He goodness.
Top with chocolate chips,
decorative swizzles or nuts.
Okay.
Put some nuts on your berries.
This Valentine's Day. Everybody,
40% off from Sherry's berries.
You just need by code burpee.
You are when you order giant romantic,
fresh and juicy. Tell a personal
Steve, tell a fucking personal story.
Sherry. Uh, here's the only way to get
these amazing Valentine's Day deal.
A giant, juicy, freshly
dipped strawberries.
We got it starting at 1999 or double
the berries for only $10 more.
Who? Kitten heel. All right. Valentine's
days. A fucking pain in the ass.
This is a nice, quick, easy
way to shut her the hell up.
Just order these goddamn things.
Visits.
berries.com please spell out
the word berries. All right.
B E R R I e s.com.
Click on the microphone.
I've said this 20 fucking times.
They're not going to buy now.
They're never going to buy. All
right, here we go. The next one.
It's the classic beyond Ds. Me
undies. No more sweaty balls.
Boop, boop, boop. Beyond
these, beyond these, you could
wear him down at the mall.
Walk up to that whore at the orange.
Julius. Why did I pick Julius?
Not the rise with debt.
Oh no more sweat on your fucking balls
running down your fucking crack. Oh yeah.
Even when you do a headstand, but
booboo, you could have dry balls.
We really beat it. Drive. Sorry.
Um, 90%. That's the percentage of your
lifetime that you spend in your underwear.
Unless you Tarzan, right?
And you've free ball it.
Can you believe fucking Tom Petty was so
petty that he sued Sam Smith over that
shit or at complete musical genius.
I love both of those fucking songs. I
would never thought to speed up, uh,
Sammy Smith Song there.
Okay.
It's gotta be weird for Sam Smith
getting sued by that fossil.
I don't want to happen to Tom
Petty. He was never, never the Ba,
the a good looking guy, but Jesus
Christ, that guy looks like a, you look.
So he works in a fucking mind
shaft in the 18 hundreds.
Ever since he became a traveling wilbury
he kind of lost that 20th century.
Look about him, didn't he? Um, uh,
what was that song they used to say?
Dad An ad and I can't
fucking remember anyways.
90% of the time he likes you spending
in your underwear. All right.
Sitting there yelling at a TV,
hoping someone's going to get elected,
that's going to change your life.
Not realizing that you have that all
the power lies within you and underwear.
It gets old fast.
Everybody,
you know that feeling of
putting on old saggy underwear,
Huh?
You need to know the feeling of putting
on great fitting underwear that is two
times softer than cotton. That's
right. They got cotton on the run here.
You need to know about me undies.com
beyond these is the most comfortable
underwear you will ever wear. And it's
insane how good they make your balls.
Fields, I wouldn't say. And they
make you feel they fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on your balls and they
literally pull moisture away from your
skin grows. Uh, so that you stay cool.
Does that doesn't make any
sense. All right. You perspire
to keep your body cool.
Pulling moisture away would
actually retain heat, wouldn't it?
I have mine on right now and I'm floating.
No I don't.
I do wear a couple of pairs other
than the fucking euro trash colors.
They are very comfortable and they
do hug my balls very nicely. Uh,
they have cool styles for both men and
ladies. Old Ladies get them to everybody.
[inaudible] no more sweaty clams.
Oh yeah.
Does it matter if you're at the beach?
But booboo,
pull it away from your Goddamn Twat.
Ah,
only be wet because you're turned on
so disgusting.
Check out the photos for yourself.
look@thesnatchesandballsonmeundies.com
this quality would typically retail for
two times the me undies price.
No retail middlemen means more savings
for you here. I'll make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burn and
get 20% off your first order and free
shipping. Save even more
when you buy a pack of them,
a whole stack of me on
these state guarantee,
you're going to be happy with them or
your first pair is free as a good gift for
you girl on Valentine's Day
buyers some fucking me undies.
Okay.
Then when she gets mad,
you just say, listen,
I'm just trying to keep the clamp dry.
I don't understand how else.
What more loving thing could I be doing
right now and keeping your clam dry.
All right, legal zoom, everybody.
What's your top New Year's resolution?
To be honest with you,
I don't think it's any of my business,
but if you're like me, it's getting
your life organized. Actually it isn't.
It's keeping my temper in
check and reading out loud
a little better. You know,
little improvements every year to become
a better me. But where do you begin?
A great place.
This
is protecting your family and a great
way to take control of your family's
future is making a will or a living trust.
It's also a great way to give them a
motivation to fucking kill you. Uh,
that's where legal zoom can help.
There's no easier way to make sure
your family is legally taken care of.
Getting your life organized also means
taking control of your financial affairs.
So if you're thinking of
starting a business or you
already have one legal zoom
can help you from,
can help you form your business and
provide the support you need to run a
success successfully
for more than 10 years.
Legal Zoom has helped millions of people
get the personalized attention that
they need.
And if you like more help,
they can connect you with an
independent attorney in most states,
but they're not a lot from this month.
You can save even more by entering bur
bur in the referral box at checkout.
That Promo Code is bird,
but you are are.
Don't let another year passed you by
before getting your life organized for
legal help you can count on for
your family or small business.
All you have to do is go to
legalzoom.com Promo Code Bur B. U.
R. R. All right, so where do we go here?
Where do we go? Here? Let me go back
to the fucking, the questions here.
Uh, God, I, there's gotta be a better
way to do this fucking cock podcasts.
Something a little more professional.
Well, how far into this are we?
1511. What's that? 26 minutes. Okay, let's
continue talking. Oh, by the way. Yeah,
I bet you're all one.
And hey bill,
did you finally have a chance to
watch the super bowl? You know
that big football game that's played
every year that your home team one? Yes,
I did. Not only did I watch it
once. Not only did I watch it twice,
I watched it three fucking times. Sorry,
I kind of plug in that she had you.
Um,
I watched it three times and uh,
it's just a hell of a fucking game.
Um,
and I actually think Edelman should have
got a co Mvp because not only did he
have a big game,
he knocked his defensive
back out of the fucking game,
you know, broke the guy's guy. Damn rests
on a wonderful fucking tackle and a,
we exploited whoever the fuck they put
in for the guy that broke his risks that
I don't know his name either because I
was traveling around the fucking world
and I don't collect football cards anymore
because they fucked up the whole way
you did it.
You know,
back in the day you could just go
out and buy a post stack of them and
eventually you'd get all of them,
you know,
now they try to make them deliberately
rare and they have like pieces of game
worn jerseys.
It's just not what it used to be.
I just wish tops would put out a set
of 390 like they used to back in the
fucking day and someone like
me could ride his bicycle down.
Old freckled face bill. You know, any
you're awful gum that was in there,
that fucked up one football
card in every pack.
Why can't I go back to doing that?
So I'd know back then,
I swear to God I could have announced the
fucking game. I knew everybody's name.
I knew the offensive linemen, defensive
linemen, I knew fucking everybody.
Now the only way to do that is you got
to play fantasy football with a bunch of
fucking jerk offs.
You got to go to somebodies living room
and have a fucking draft as you sit
there with adults acting like, just
see, oh is of a fucking league.
That doesn't even exist. It's one of the
saddest, most pathetic fucking thanks.
Anyway, so let's talk about the game.
Um, even though it's way over. Uh,
okay.
Um, obviously the excitement wasn't
there cause I already knew the,
I knew the end result,
but I was anticipating how I
would feel throughout the game.
I would say that when Brady threw
the pic, uh, in the beginning,
um,
I guess with the broken wrist,
I guess that that would have made me
feel like they kind of offset. But, uh,
I always get nervous when someone says a
turnover and I'm thinking, like I said,
it's going to be the first in many
definitely when we were down by 10,
I definitely would have been like,
it's over.
We're not coming back from this shit.
And uh,
you know, that ridiculous catch. I
would've completely freaked out. But um,
I'll tell you, everybody's given
Pete Carroll Shit. You know,
they had a great stat that I saw.
I'm usually not a big stack guy,
but that play that Pete Carroll called
that was run a little over a hundred
times during the regular season.
It resulted in like 65 touchdowns
or low sixties touchdowns,
like 40 incomplete completions and like
no interceptions or something like that.
It was like 64. No, like 65,
66, something like that.
Touchdown. Right. And
45 was a little over a hundred times.
They tried it,
but there was never an
interception until that place.
So it's just one of those fucking
things. And God, if anybody knows,
it's just one of those fucking things.
It's a patriots fan with
like the helmet catch,
you know that fucking ridiculous pass at
Eli through after Brady to Welker shit
the bed. Um, but you know,
it was fucking hilarious.
Was seeing Tom Brady space after that
ridiculous catch that that guy in the
Seahawks mate, he's just, he just
had this look on his face like,
like really like how many times
do I have to win the Superbowl?
Okay.
Before I,
I actually,
and the defense will just fucking
get a goddamn three and out.
It led me ice to fucking game.
How many fucking times?
So I got to drive down the fucking
field for the, go ahead. Touchdown.
I did it in both fucking giants games
and you guys are out there letting people
catch it between that taint in their
fucking ankle for the love of fucking God.
You know that whoever that Patriot
was that jumped up and over,
that's the result of those fucking don't,
don't hit a defenseless
receiver cause back in the day,
even though Malcolm Butler
tip that ball up debt,
other that's safety coming over the top,
he would have gone right into that
guy's jaw. Even a hurdle in like, oh,
don't step on the receiver and wouldn't
knock the ball out. So thank God.
And uh, I loved seeing a drunk, um,
Robert Kraft and I loved that he demanded
an apology and that fucking gym or say
what a bunch of Horse Shit.
Did you guys see that thing
ESPN did where they had the, uh,
the science guy actually investigated
the advantages or disadvantages of a
deflated ball and they
actually found out that it was,
it was actually a disadvantage.
Um,
yeah,
but there's an article that came out
that I retweeted that grant it was from,
it was from like CBS Sports Boston
that really debunked a lot of the shit.
Of course you guys won't
believe it, but, um, you know,
I dunno what I hope that they
pursue that they should pursue that.
The way the colts complained
throughout the years.
Just keep complaining right
through the fucking draft.
All I know is the fucking bill Belicheck
sat on the rules committee and change
rules to make the game
easier for his offense.
I mean he would have to go on in
front of the Senate defending himself.
Jim Mercy does it. Nobody gives
a fuck. Um, so that's my message.
Fuck Jim, our sec. What are you
going to cry about this year, Jimmy?
Um, anyways, what else?
I'm trying to look at
my list of Shit here.
Anything else that I wanted to talk about?
Uh,
Oh and I lost my list. Well, I
guess that, well, there goes that,
um, anyways, I'm in Not New York City for
the, uh, the Patrice O'Neal events, um,
benefit I should say. Uh, the third
annual time is flying by and uh,
this is such a wonderful event. So most
positive thing I do every year. And, um,
we've got a hell of a lineup this year
as always. A, we got some new faces,
we've got some new, uh,
this is the first year.
We actually fact we've got a couple
guys on that were, uh, you know,
I think got to see Patrice
before they were even comics,
I'm guessing by their age.
Michael Che in Hannibal Burress.
So that's pretty cool to
have that sort of element.
Like watching people who were influenced
by Patrice has comedy before they
started, or at least very
early on in their career,
they were able to see him. Um,
so I'm really looking forward to that.
And once again,
it's just such a great benefit and a,
all you guys who've gone out throughout
the years in a bought tickets,
it's really, you know, had such a positive
effect on,
uh,
the people that Patrice
loved because you know,
unlike a lot of fucking charities where
there's an infrastructure and there's
people getting paid, nobody
gets paid. Like I said,
the only money we have to spend is the
money that to rent out the venue and then
the rest of it goes to his level. And
so it's really just like direct, like,
you know, when you want to help
wounded warriors and veterans,
like you just wish you could just be like,
give me the name of the person and where
they live and can I just fucking write
a check to this person directly?
Um,
then of course then they would just
put it in the bank and then it would be
considered income and then they get taxed
on it. Right. Is that what it is? Uh,
these fucking cuts. I don't
know how to do it. Uh,
but I think the way we're doing it
is about the best way you can do it.
By the way, did you see all
that shit on fucking no more
that they don't really do anything
other than just raise awareness.
It's the biggest fuck any,
I'm telling you right now.
I am done with any charity that says
they're there to raise awareness.
Fuck no more. Fuck that. Uh, pink
shit in October. All of them.
It's a bunch of it.
They're the modern day slim,
slam snake oil salesman.
They're all getting rich off of,
of of people dying of
diseases or get beaten up,
spousal abuse,
all of that.
They literally going out buying fancy
cars and nice houses because regular
people feel like they're doing
something. I don't know. I don't know.
Of course.
And I haven't investigated any of it.
I think they're all full of Shit and uh,
I'm done with it now I'm done.
But I'm done with,
I think I'm pretty much done but
just about every one of other than a,
okay.
What's that one that Danny Thomas started.
Okay.
That one has just straight
up like a five star rating.
Is it Saint Jude's hospital?
That one.
And then the thing I talked
about a few weeks ago,
which I still haven't done
cause I've been overseas, we,
she'd see if you're a match for
the, uh, bone marrow transplant,
we thinking literally
saved somebodies life.
Like those types of charities that are
transparent. There's just a handful of,
if you know. But isn't that, isn't
that the truth with everything?
I mean there's a lot of
people that play music,
but how they are really good
charities are no different. Everybody.
All right, let's get on with, um,
okay.
How is this a bad thing?
Is it bad
to think someone's a bad mother
because they still wear leather pants?
It's probably a bad thing,
right?
I'm here in New York and I was sitting
down eating at yet another bad slice of
pizza in New York City.
You know,
New York City is just like Chicago
where it's known for its pizza.
So there's so many fucking places that
are living off that reputation that like,
you know,
you have to talk to somebody that lives
in Chicago and they'll tell you where to
go.
And pretty much still there's like five
fucking places maybe in each city that
people will recommend it and
everything else is bullshit.
So this place across the street of course
is bullshit. And I'm sitting there,
I meet my slice of pizza and they
got some sort of a Latino judge,
Judy thing going on. And, uh,
which is just at a total different level
where on this show the defendants can
actually put their hands on each other,
I guess once once a, uh, the
prosecution, once it, the family,
whatever I want to have
the fucking legal term.
It's the person bitching and the person
getting bitched at. They can actually,
like when this guy,
he actually ran up to this
woman and ripped her shirt
open and pulled out, like,
I don't know if he was bitching
that her bra was stuffed and uh,
that's what he was suing her over
some sort of false advertising.
I have no idea the sound was down.
And even if it was up,
it was in a different language and I was
the only one watching it other than the
guy making pizza.
So when he ripped her shirt open,
I screamed out what this pizza place?
And everyone's looking at me like,
what am I talking about?
By the time they looked up,
they'd cut away. So I dunno.
Maybe they thought I was some sort of red,
had a Latino guy and I could read
lips or some shit. I don't know. What,
but anyway, so this woman walks in,
his lady walks in with the two kids.
She's got a leather pants and high
heels shoes and just right there.
I just immediately judge was like,
she's,
she's too fucking self
involved to be a good mom.
Then I was like though you too. Oh,
because of what? Her pants and her shoes.
Yeah.
Am I wrong for saying that ladies?
I would love to hear from you.
And is there the male equivalent to that?
Wouldn't that be like the guy,
if you saw a guy,
he's a dad of two when he comes in and
he's got his hair highlighted in his
fucking eyebrows shaped up,
you know,
looking like he's trying to do the a book,
a role for the Ricky Martin Story.
You know, maybe wearing
some Cologne, you know,
aren't the both of them
still kind of horn it up?
Like are you still trying to find a mate?
Like what's going on here?
Probably everything.
I said, you know what,
somebody's probably gonna take an extra
for that and then put it on there and
then it'll be a little sexless rats,
although blood,
they bullying ass fucking
morons. Um, anyways.
Yeah. There you go. I'm just
being honest, like I feel like a,
if I see a woman with kids,
she's wearing leather pants. Uh,
I'm going to say that, uh, I dunno,
somebody might fall in a swimming pool
and it's going to take you a minute to
get there.
Okay.
Ah, Shit. Anyways, Hong Kong, h o n k,
Honk Kong, by the way, people who live
in Hong Kong are known as honkies.
How funny is that? Well, I
think it's funny. Hang on.
MMM,
yeah. Right. Hong Kong, Hong
Kong. Oh, by the way, India,
there's so many fucking people.
They're like you.
It takes you a minute to be able
to breathe that fucking air.
I definitely felt like I've done a
couple of times live in, in Los Angeles.
I've gone on a hike, you know,
in my leather pants, you know,
but I don't have any children,
so it's okay.
My leather hiking shorts and if
I am jogging a little bit and,
um, you know, breathing hard or
whatever, I felt a burning in my chest
on a, like really smoggy days. But, uh,
I was not jogging when I was in
India and there was definitely this,
this like, you know, it takes a
second fee about it to get you so, oh,
it's going to be this level,
you know?
MMM.
Having said all of that and as much as
a pain in the ass as it was to get the
fucking slip and all that,
I can't wait to go back.
Uh,
alright. Hong Kong bill, you
probably already talked about this,
but can you speak about the pollution
and the constant tickle in your throat
caused by the air over there
if you haven't already? Oh,
that's what somebody experienced that
in Hong Kong. I didn't feel that.
I felt that in India. I felt there
was that tickle in your throat?
MMM,
there was definitely,
it was definitely hazy,
but la gets hazy.
MMM.
But, uh, I would think
a lot of that was, yeah.
There's just a zillion people over there.
MMM.
Yeah, I dunno. I don't want to start
saying a bunch of negative shit.
It's already enough negative shit
about a lot of places over there.
They're fucking amazing cities to go
to. I highly recommend it. But yeah,
there's definitely a zillion people and
you see the effects on the environment,
which is why it's funny when people deny
global warming and that we're having
any sort of an effect on the
environment or any of that type of shit.
And the little for years that was
the fucking earth is heated up and
cooled down. Jesus fucking Christ.
Um,
I am not a scientist,
but they seem to be very alarmed at the
rate that it is heating up this time and
this time of year, people always
point at snow storms and go ese.
It's snowing in February.
Uh,
this one scientist guy was saying that
both the summers and the winters are
going to have, are going to
be really erratic. And uh,
all I can say about it is I hope that the,
the,
the people who say it
isn't true are right.
Because if we're having effect on it and
we're not fucking with the population
other than to keep adding
to it, uh Oh my God.
I almost said the worst joke ever.
Forecast calls for a shitstorm. Oh,
I'm such a Gemini,
sorry.
Sorry to anybody who ever remotely even
liked or enjoyed comedy because I just
ruined it, a part of it.
You know what I mean?
What I just did to comedy with that awful
joke was like during a war when a city
gets bombed and uh,
you know,
a really old historic
building gets blown up.
That's what I just did really built.
I think he just told a bad joke.
I think comedy will be fine. You fucking
jerk off. All right. Foreign music. Billy,
have you developed a love for any
music you've heard while traveling?
Um,
I traveled so much,
I didn't have a chance to take
in to too much of anything. Um,
I will tell you that, uh, when I was in
Singapore,
I think it was in Singapore,
I walked into that hotel that has
the infinity pool at the top at your,
you're not allowed to go into,
I discovered unless you were a guests,
I just wanted to walk out and go
see it. And they were like, ah, no,
I'm sorry I can't do that. And
then the lady was like, well,
he's doing a show here in
town. And they're like, yeah,
well have fun at the show.
You still can't look at the pool.
Um,
when I was in the lobby of that hotel,
there was a,
it was these women playing.
MMM.
I don't know if these instruments from
Asia basically, as far as I can tell you,
you know that one that has to strings,
but you hit it with little hammers.
They haven't. And every karate
movies that I've ever watched, um,
not during a fight scene.
It's usually when the person comes
to the hero comes to town and,
uh,
the hot girl in the village
that the Douche bag that
the heroes is going to have
to fight. Notice, notice this is
the hair off when it comes to town.
And then that guy immediately hates the
hero and then they have to fight over
her vagina basically. Um, you know,
that instrument that's played in
the background. I liked that one.
And I liked the music. I like the moods
that that creates. Uh, by the way,
I'll tell you right now, Chinese
girls, a fucking hot man. Good Lord.
Beautiful fucking stunning.
Um,
same thing with the women is Singapore.
They all got some cutie pies. You
know, every God damn country I went to,
every country has cutie pies.
I'll tell you that.
Say That right now and
have as far as music,
I didn't fuck listen anything other
than I heard that shit in the lobby. Um,
that was a, you know, it's funny with the
hotel we were staying at and, and, and uh,
Hong Kong, they, uh,
they had all these beautiful
fucking women working there.
All these Chinese women, right? And
they all had names like Susan and Ethel,
meg.
And then you'd walk out and go to a store
across the street and everybody would
have like Chinese names. And it's just
like Jesus Christ. What are you doing it?
I know your name is Helen.
Okay.
Fuck, I forgot to do that joke
when I was in, you know what?
I wanted to open with an India. I was
just so fucking tired. I forgot I was,
I wanted to open with like,
you know what? You know what?
I was nice to be here in India and I
know I've already probably talked to most
of you on the phone.
And by the way, we all,
everybody in America knows your name
is Scott. You don't need to do that.
Is there anything else I can help
you with? What is your name? Scott.
Okay.
No it isn't.
My name is Dakota.
That's going to be funny when the
updated to those fucking awful
celebrity names.
People name their kids now the
fuck do they name him? Your name?
Your kid like carburetor or
some dumb shit like that? Uh,
you help my wife give
birth the fuck out of here.
Um, well she heard that joke I did a few
minutes ago. She'd have a miscarriage. Uh,
you helped me with my wife.
Give birth. Dear Billy boy,
I am writing to you from my lovely wife's
hospital room and she gave birth to
our beautiful and thankfully not
redheaded little lady. Oh fuck you.
Uh, my wife was a complete
ship going through 29,
long hours of labor.
Holy Shit.
The what did they get bitch longer than
we can if they're fucking bill to take
29 hours of labor,
you think you're going to beat them in
a fight about whether you can watch the
game or not. Fucking it's over
before it starts. One round loss.
Um, and now I have a huge respect for
mothers everywhere after seeing what an
intense process that is firsthand.
Anyways, that's hilarious.
It took 29 hours of labor.
At what point did your,
your opinion start to change our 17.
Do you know? I ain't got to say Seo.
These mothers, they got
something. Um, that's funny.
Then I'm judging that lady
wearing the fucking leather pants.
She probably went through
29 hours to write,
at least between the two kids and the
fact that she can still fit into leather
pants, you know, I dunno.
Maybe that's my insecurity,
but I think she's still
trolling for cock. Uh, anyways,
let's take that out of context.
Let's just shove that somewhere.
Put that on the news.
Anyways,
my reason for writing is
while she was in labor,
I tried to play some music to help
distract her from the, from the uh,
contractions. After about three songs
and a few contractions, she said to me,
and I quote, this music isn't
helping. I need something
else. Put on bill burrs,
podcasts, bullshit.
Jesus Christ was,
that's probably why she pushed it out.
She wanted US fucking stop
hearing my dumb voice.
Obviously I obliged a woman giving birth
to my child and we sat there listening
to old freckles distractive
from the pains of labor.
I am sure that nurses were a bit confused
when they heard a litany of shits,
fucks and cons coming from the phone.
But we didn't care because it was helping.
Thanks for all you do and for helping
distract my wife for awhile from her
uterus trying to push a little little
wrecking ball through the birth canal.
Thanks. And Go fuck
yourself. Well there you go.
See that like podcasts can be
used for things that are good.
Right? Isn't that lovely? All right,
go on to the next one. A
coworker, dear William,
there's a woman,
or as I like to say,
fuck and lady at my,
at my workplace who I am in love with a,
there was a project and I was handpicked.
Oh fuck. I just forgot. You know, this is,
you know,
something that I love about traveling
is the random shit that you see.
Somebody bought me a cigar.
Yeah.
Um, when I was in New Zealand,
thank you, by the way.
And they had a cutter and matches
and all that shit. Not Everybody.
You heard that? And I said,
thank you. Please don't do that.
Nobody else do that because I'm really
trying to cut down my habit. Um,
but I appreciate the gesture. So
anyways, he gets me that. And by the way,
if you're gonna pick out a fucking cigar,
you got to pinch the ENT where you put
your mouth and it's supposed to be spongy,
supposed to go in,
and they want to come,
supposed to immediately come back and
then it's going to have a nice draw.
The rest of the cigar, it doesn't
fucking matter. All right. And, uh,
cause if it's hard where
you put your mouth, um,
it's like you ever have like a straw
and a milkshake that's too thick and you
can't even fucking enjoy it. Uh,
that's what ends up happening.
But having said that,
that's another reason why I don't want
to fucking cigar from someone in the
crowd because if you actually pinching it,
I don't know where your fingers are bent
and is, it just gets gross. So anyways,
but I'm smoking the cigar anyways and uh,
I'm in Auckland,
New Zealand,
right?
Yeah.
Had a great show,
played this unbelievable theater and they
had this Oregon there that it was one
of the top five or six organs
in the world. Um, and you know,
you see an Oregon with those giant pipes,
you just think they're playing and
that's the pipes that you seeing is,
is you know, with, and be all that
music's coming from. It isn't,
it's actually those pipes are uh,
just for shelf for the most part.
And you go in the back. We, she
took, this lady took me in the back,
there was three floors of inner workings
to this Oregon and are telling you
like giant rooms of things that you know,
opened and contracted like
a goddamn accordion and then
all these different size
pipes all the way down to these little
things you could smoke crack out of that
all were part of that sound and I guess
these old guys would come in. Yeah.
Every, uh, like monks
to retune it, you know,
I don't even know if it needs to
be tuned that many times, but uh,
I guess they love the fucking
Oregon so much. They used to joke,
it was like their train
set. But um, anyway,
so it's just as far as like random shit
that you see some smoking this cigar
and it's like one in the morning,
I mean fucking New Zealand,
other side of the world all the way down
there. Fucking Antartica it feels like.
And all of a sudden somebody walks by,
I swear to God,
it's like a Mitchell and
ness art monk Jersey,
a Washington Redskins Jersey. I'm looking
at is that a fucking Redskins Jersey?
I mean Auckland, New Zealand and then
look at the back and it's, it's art monk.
Not only is it a choice,
a fucking great joke.
Who the fuck has an art monk Jersey? Great
Choice. What are the health? Has that,
that's one of my,
uh,
I hated him when he played because I
was a big time cowboys fan back then
before,
uh,
ill Jimmy's face facelift
came in there and uh,
Jerry Jerry facelifts came in.
Okay.
Jerry Jones and Jimmy Johnson.
I was,
I've never been able to keep those
two straight. Uh, so anyways, I liked,
that's the type of shit I like.
It's just the randomness of that
I saw and there's a bunch of,
of bootleg Yankee Shit because wearing
like a Yankees hat or anything New York
is just like, you know, it's like the
fucking chicken. Where's the parish shirt?
That's never been there for a
little Eiffel tower someday day.
But they're not like Yankee fans.
Actually,
I heard a funny story of some mets fan,
I guess fucking living overseas and
couldn't stand that because none of them
because he wanted to like shit on the
Yankees as a mets fan. Like, I don't know,
it doesn't really have a leg to stand on.
But uh,
he find out that they were just
wearing them to wear them. And uh, oh,
the other thing too is when you go into
a country that doesn't really speak
English, I've told you this shit
and I saw this in France where like,
like the shit that they have an English
never makes any sense or it doesn't,
you know, it doesn't mean
what they thought it meant.
Like when I was in Hong Kong,
I was reading their tee shirts,
the way they read our tattoos,
you know,
we get the Chinese characters where you
think like this means like brotherhood.
This means serenity and it really
just means like a, you know,
take a left on fuckhead street or
whatever the hell it means. Um,
somebody had a,
yeah.
Oh Christ. I knew I should have
written down. I can't remember.
Okay.
Somebody actually had a football jersey,
but the numbers 69 on it and where
the name when it's said all night,
all night 69.
There you go.
This guys wants to get some and give some
all at the same time. Good for him. Uh,
anyways, coworker dare bill.
There's a lady at my workplace
who I am in love with.
There was a project and I was handpicked
to help out in her department.
Not sure why, but there were plenty of
other people who could have done it. Well,
maybe it was fate, maybe it was
cupid, maybe it was, I dunno what,
something bringing it together. Anyways,
this person says, because of this,
we have worked together on numerous
occasions when I'm doing something on the
computer and she's sitting
beside me helping out,
I can't help but notice she's
looking directly at me. Jesus, Buddy.
How many more fucking
signs do you need here?
Sometimes she will be one
aisle over bent over a desk.
Okay.
Talking to someone and adjusting her
tight jeans where she knows I can see it.
Okay, this took a left turn. I ain't seen
relationship here, buddy. I'm seeing,
uh,
seeing a fun time for about six weeks
and then I'm seeing you losing your job.
That's what I'm saying now. All
right, let's keep reading here.
We work in a large building and she has
all the way on the other side, so weak.
So we correspond by text messaging.
All that's always good. Good move,
good move. Get it in writing, write
something lewd to her. Uh, believe me,
she'll keep every one of
these and when it goes south,
she'll fucking show it to your boss
who probably also wants to banger. Um,
we work in a large building way my way.
Oftentimes when I text her
about work or have questions,
she doesn't respond.
I'm guessing if she was into me,
she would reply back immediately,
but touch, sometimes I get nothing.
Or is she playing hard to get?
I really want to make a move,
but there is a fear of hostile
work environment or worse,
I get fired for sexual harassment if she
doesn't have the same feelings towards
me, it's killing me not knowing what to
do because all I do is think about our
thanks and go fuck yourself. Ps, I'm
married and have kids and so does she. Oh,
fuck you. And that was a big waste
of time. Ah, Jesus Christ. All right,
I think that's a podcast for this
week, right? That's not, that's that.
That was a pretty decent effort. Once
you say decent effort all the way around,
uh, that's the podcast.
I want to thank everybody
who came out to my shows as
I toured the south of Asia.
I still can't believe I got to do that.
It was fucked up.
I was in two countries that had one
of the wonders of the world and I saw
neither one of them.
I didn't go to the Great Wall
and I didn't go to the Taj Mahal.
Uh,
so
yeah. What are you going to
fucking do it? I tried. You know,
I did my think. Um, anyway,
so I am in New York City right now and
I'm doing the Patrice Patrice O'Neal
benefit tomorrow night. And uh, I
dunno, I'm on different time zone.
I might go out to the clubs
tonight. Who knows? Who knows?
That's the Monday morning podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
Thanks to listening and I will talk to
each and every one of you next week.
All right. Thank you for your patience.
I know it's coming out later. See Ya.